hello and welcome to this video playing
Tim ICC okay I'm sticking with my main
repertoire and see what we get Jack good
taste of scotch headline is slightly
questionable for black but okay as long
as it doesn't get refuted every game I'm
I'm going for it
hmm i wonder if I did something wrong
here imma plate there's a million times
but still I feel I'm doing something
wrong okay have to give my queen some
square neither three is a pretty
substantial threat
and took a long time looked very logical
neither three okay so yeah that's not a
happy move but probably have to yeah
very very murky position why does
probably canceling law which means he's
castling into the open B file okay maybe
this long cast lots Bishop a three years
or something that he probably cannot
allow yeah and now is this is the one of
my favorite rules and chest if human
play be four ng for you have no care no
good King position anymore yes on the
other hand White's got tons tons of
space see fire this night pins night f5
okay that might be really bad in
practice six but I want to prevent 95
and I have c5 coming after which my
bishop might find some some some work
there on b7
yeah it's not so bad maybe at least I
currently don't see a clear reputation
and according to the bng paudwal white
skin has some long-term issues good move
probably ok that's the check you fall
and now I have to see that i get d 5 and
I guess I wonder if you can go see form
c4d 65 looks dangerous anyway don't have
much choice then I need to my bishop CA
to do something next very likely st5
unless you play c4 then I probably have
to play this 6 okay Miriam do shows you
cannot take because of Karelia fade
winning the house
yeah his King the king now asks the
white player what did she do there with
the PNG porn where am I supposed to go
yeah it's all rather unclear of course
it's not like I'm winning mmmk just
taking the three or
no I guess I'll just take T 3 mm it's
good rookie one coming it's kind of
annoying and I can't die let's do this
that's actually good / I think if he
takes his King position is completely
open I mean take on c6 and now I'm ready
for that rookie one move that this
doesn't hurt so much it takes it i play
Bishop b6 that let must be a fantastic
attack rook BD 8 i'm coming Bishop c4
know that that's a good position
I can take p3 hand but it might not be
and it's actually not super clear let's
keep more than more stuff on the board
I guess screen c2 is so many more then I
wanted to play Bishop t5 but maybe there
are alternatives that are stronger
okay and it shouldn't be bad right and
he's got no time at all yeah to take or
not to take that's the question okay
rubbing here first hmm
hmm yeah I think I'll take it but i'm
not sure i'm really not sure written
it's pretty clear that black must be
fine here but if it is the maximum
wasn't clear to me probably not I'm how
to enter now Queen seafoam maybe start
with this 27 that's rookie one
maybe g6 maybe g6 and then try to go
onto to the long diagonal now Queen at
425 and here going for Queenie form okay
I'm winning the same time work its
meaning on time I mean the position is
great but ok it is winning actually
minus 2y a tough game this is a very
weird opening yeah I think that all made
made sense to me at least and now after
that before yeah this is the thing that
the White King it's not having a clear
the clear on homie IM the computer
actually just wants to cancel short and
there is some logic to that I mean the
King feels reasonably saved them in
comparison to other areas of the board
ok this was plate 96 I have to get that
into the game and provoke f3 no this
year I felt like a 4c for should be
critical here like c-46 I don't think
this works I think this is really just a
pawn so we asked to maybe this a now
continue for me I was thinking this kind
of position and if this is very weird
hear that my bishop looks terrible but I
have some positive side see also night
comes to e5 d4 is weak and again the
White King doesn't have a clear clear
place to go yeah this is probably not
good now I'm opening up the position
here yea i meant it here yeah the
computers giving me Sh are already a
pretty substantial advantage even though
it wants to play look the 8th here
interesting but that cannot be bad i
don't think it's bad yeah slight edge
0.3 0.4 but here i know whether that's
at least i think close to impossible to
defend for you
this position with black being so active
in here check and this is actually
winning from like yeah I wasn't sure
it's always tough to give up the pair of
bishops especially in a situation where
the bishops look like they can both
participate in the attack but I'm
getting two points here and whites King
is still in huge danger so it's probably
a good choice okay well thanks for
watching